I'd like to buy
these sunglasses.
Are you
that girl from live TV
who said
we're all gonna die?
No. What's your purchase?
-What the fuck?
-Nah, that's you.
-It's definitely you.
-Yup. That's me.
Holy shit.
You're a stone-cold legend.
Word is bond.
Got a picture of you
on my board.
Picture of you
on his fucking board.
That's great.
What's your purchase?
If you don't have one, I
need you to get out of line
to make room
for the other customers.
Can I touch your hair
in a non-sexual way?
-Get the fuck away from me.
-No, dude, have some…
Um…
Call Diogo,
he's gonna freak out.
Will you say hi
to my friend?
He's obsessed with you.
We love you! We don't like…
Can't stand Orlean either.
-Yo. Yo, yo, yo.
-Yo, yo, yo!
What's up? Shut the…
Yo, shut the fuck up.
Check out who we're with.
-Yo, bro!
-What up!
Look at her!